thank you  Dad we're broke you can't keep spending  money on junk  something in here needs to make this  family some money bring it up all the  way  come on you old wreck  Judgment day look it's not normal steel  I don't think it's a truck at all  I think we just found a Transformer  trying to protect your family  that's admirable I'm trying to defend  the nation you have no idea what you're  involved with here I'm going to ask you  this once where is Optimus Prime after  all we have done humans are hunting us  as world as he knows it is gone  but I fear we are all Targets now  what is that a great threat is coming  this is not war  it's human extinction  the rules have changed  foreign  foreign